c'est l'heure du second débat de ce sens
public il nous ramène en Ukraine la
guerre a été en grande partie éclipsée
par le conflit au au Proche Orient
depuis 7 octobre mais évidemment les
combats continuent l'armée ukrainienne a
réussi à établir des positions sur la
rive du fleuve de niepr qui était juste
ici sous contrôle russe est-ce le début
d'une Persée significative avant d'en
débattre on fait le point sur la
situation militaire avec Lina
boueroui une arrivée surprise à Kiev
pour nouveau ministre des Affaires
étrangères britanniques David Cameron a
choisi l'Ukraine pour sa première visite
l'ancien Premier ministre avait déclaré
sur Twitter faire de la situation en
Ukraine l'une de ses priorités il
concrétise cette annonce en confirmant
l'êre de 5,3 milliards d'euros je
confirme en venant ici que le
Royaume-Uni continuera d'apporter son
soutien moral et diplomatique à
l'Ukraine le Royaume-Uni est le trème
pays contributeur à l'effort de guerre
ukrainien à hauteur de 14 milliards
d'euros derrière les États-Unis et
l'Allemagne depuis le début de
l'invasion en février 2022 l'ancien
pensionnaire de Downing Street réaffirme
le soutien du Royaume-Uni à l'Ukraine
une visite bienvenue pour vlodimir
Zelenski alors que tous les regards sont
tournés vers le proche orient ces
dernières
semaines le monde n'est pas concentré
sur nous et la guerre que nous menons je
suis ravi que vous soyez
présent sur le front les difficultés
militaires ukrainiennes s'intensifient
de nouvelles attaques russes ont frappé
les régions du zaporidia et du doniesque
les troupes ukrainiennes ont besoin
d'armement tandis que les ressources
militaires
s'amenuisent l'Union européenne s'est
également engagé à aider l'Ukraine un
soutien financier qui sera discuté lors
des négociations concernant l'adhésion
du territoire à l'Union européenne les
14 et 15 décembre à
Bruxelles la contreoffensive ukrainienne
peut-elle sortir de l'impasse l'aide
internationale a-t-elle atteint son
maximum voilà deux des questions qu'
l'on va aborder tout de suite avec mes
invités David Rigou rose bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes chercheur à
l'Institut français d'analyse
stratégique chercheur associé à Liris et
rédacteur en chef de la revue Orient
stratégique Mariana peressou bonsoir et
bienvenue journaliste Franco ukrainienne
j'accueille Patrick Martin jeunier
bonsoir et bienvenue professeur à
Science Po spécialiste des questions
européennes et vous publiez l'Europe
a-t-elle un avenir au missmission
studirama évidemment Mathilde Sirot est
resté à mes côtés littctorialiste
politique David rigolero je commence
avec vous les les projecteurs des médias
mais aussi des politiques du monde
entier ont un peu beaucoup délaissé
l'Ukraine depuis le 7 octobre j'allais
vous poser une question tellement
générale que s'est-il passé depuis 6
semaines est-ce que la la situation
militaire a a tellement évolué ou est-ce
qu'on est effectivement dans une sorte
de GLA là non elle a pas
fondamentalement évolué c'est le
problème d'ailleurs c'est c'est ce qui
ressortait de de la l'interview qui av
été accordée à Z économiste début
novembre par zalouni
le qui a été prise d'ailleurs il y a eu
des une tension avec zelensk là-dessus
parce que il reconnaissait qu'il y avait
un risque
d'enlisement il était très transparent
dans dans le diagnostic qu'il
faisait il reconnaissait même qu'il
s'était trompé sur
l'évaluation que les les pertes russes
énormes auraient pu ement arrêter la
machine de guerre russe et il reconnaît
que ça était pas ça n'était pas le cas
et qu'effectivement bon les les Russes
sont préparé des mois à à la
contreoffensive et donc il y a bah oui
il y a une situation qui qui
effectivement est bloquée et là ce qui
pardon nous interromp là ce qui s'est
joué ces derniers jours autour de du
fleuve nipre et le fait que des soldats
Ukrainiens soient passés dans la zone
qui était juste quiici sous contrôle
russe est-ce que ça change quand même la
donne ça a été reconnu pour la première
fois officiellement par un par un chef
de l'administration russe oui hier je
crois oui oui c'est ça effectivement il
y a des éléments de la 35e 36e et
38e enfin des troupes de marin justement
ukrainiennees qui sont installé on sait
pas exactement combien mais ça change
pas la donne fondamentalement c'est
c'est un indicateur que les Ukrainiens
maintiennent la pression mais il y a pas
eu ce que disaient lessk enfin ce que
disait plutôt zalouni il y a pas eu de
percée décisive qui soit un Game changer
ouais Mar votre av là-dessus sur le ce
qui
se c'estes combats autour du fleuve
nièpre et et ce qui a été reconnu
effectivement par un officiel russe hier
je je posais la question en titre est-ce
le début d'une percée significative
comment vous le percevez euh justement
pour l'instant ce n'est pas un Game
changer en soi ça peut le devenir si par
la suite on arrive à à faire profiter
enfin à profiter de cette situation
maintenant ce que nous voyons depis des
mois c'est la poursuite suite de la même
stratégie on a déjà on s'est rendu
compte que cette stratégie elle elle
était très loin de ce que prédisaient
les experts occidentaux mais qui par
ailleurs n'avait pas assez de d'éléments
même pour prédire ces percé
significatives et clair tout simplement
parce que c'est comme ça que que que que
doit être l'offensive les Ukrainiens
apparemment ont planifi les Ukrainiens
ont apparemment planifié ce qu'ils
pouvaient faire avec ce qu'ils avaient
il continueent à faire une sorte de
Marathon si vous voulez à à à à à à
faire la pression à n'est pas lâcher à
n'est pas à n'est pas lâcher la pression
donc ils poursuivent leur stratégie on
voit que ça porte des fruits on voit que
par la suite ça peut changer la donne
parce que quand même dans la région de
zaporidja on a déjà les lignes de
défense qui sont rompu donc ça peut
devenir un jour un une sorte de euh de
point de de départ d'une offensive voilà
d'une percée et de l'autre côté bah là
ça peut faire une une un deuxième point
de percée pour l'instant nous n'en
sommes pas là Patrick Martin jeunier ce
cette percée ou cette petite percée
autour du du du fleuve nipre il faut
aussi se dire dire les choses ça a causé
de lourde perte côté ukrainien à quel
prix les soldats Ukrainiens sont passés
de l'autre côté c'est un débat qui a
lieu en Ukraine je rencontre des
Ukrainiens et des ukrainiennes qui ont
des des opinions un peu diversifié on va
dire sur ce sujet je crois ce qui est
important c'est de montrer effectivement
que les forces ukrainiennes continuent a
progressé alors ce n'est pas un un
marathon c'est une progression lente
beaucoup de morts en fa effectivement on
évoque plusieurs centaines du côté
ukrainien mais il y en a aussi du côté
russe notamment à vitka plus au nord
bien évidemment il y a un aspect
toujours psychologique très important de
conviction les Ukrainiens continuent à
résister ils ont effectivement une
percée au niveau du demièpre alors que
pendant des semaines et ben ça ça
n'avait pas vraiment avancer on reste
plus que jamais dans une guerre dite
d'attrition mais dans des conditions
difficiles avec l'hiver qui a proche on
a dit que les Russes allaient
effectivement faire des des offensives
contre les infrastructures énergétiques
mais cette offensive est importante
parce qu'elle continue à montrer que les
Ukrainiens résistent et peuvent encore
avancer donc c'est quelque chose de tout
à fait encourageant ce qui veut dire
bien évidemment il y a un Conseil
européen au mois de décembre qu'il faut
continuer à soutenir l'Ukraine alors
vous l'avez évoqué cette question de
l'impasse ou ou non et et c'estes deux
son de cloches différents euh entre le
chef d'état-major le commandant chef de
l'armée ukrainienne il disait la guerre
est à un point mort le président
volodimir zensk lui a répondu 3 jours
plus tard on écoute le président
ukrainien il ne s'agit pas d'uneasse je
le répète nous en avons déjà
parlé la Russie contrôle le ciel nous
protégeons nos
militaires nous protégeons nos garçons
et nos
filles il contrôle le ciel personne ne
veut simplement jeter les gens comme de
la viande alors je voudrais vous
entendre sur ce que ce qu'il y a
derrière ces ces deux prises de parole à
quelques jours d'intervalle est-ce que
c'est voilà le signe que effectivement
il y a des courants peut-être politiques
qui s'expriment qui des des des
tiraillements internes au sein de la de
ceux qui décident de de de la
stratégie guerrière de l'Ukraine on est
sur de registres différents parce que le
Président zenski il vend évidemment le
la demande de soutien notamment auprès
des alliés donc c'est pas la même
position que le chef d'état-major qui
lui est sur le terrain avec les avec les
hommes en principe c'est complémentaire
on pourrait dire on est pardon vous
interrompe on est on est dans que que
c'est aussi le but recherché par le chef
d'étatmajor c'est on est dans l'impasse
donc donnez-nous plus d'armes ou
d'autres armes oui d'ailleurs c'est
c'est il le dit he dans l'interview il
dit aussi qu'il y a une responsabilité
des Occidentaux qui ont tardé à donner
certaines armes notamment de à longue
portée et que ça induit effectiv des
retards dans opérationnel donc il le dit
hein simplement il y a des tensions
clairement entre entre le les deux têtes
politiques et militaires qui sont
apparus d'ailleurs il y a eu des
limogages ces derniers temps qui ont été
contesté de proche notamment de du de de
zalouni et on voit bien qu'il a il y a
un problème pour le président Zelenski
parce que il a peur que effectivement
l'attention qui se porte sur le Proche
Orient miniminise celle qui qu'il attend
évidemment pour l'Ukraine et on le voit
avec ce qui s'est passé dernièrement au
Congrès puisque lors de pour éviter le
shotdown il y a eu un accord entre
démocrate répuain on va pas aller trop
vite le shutdown on explique c'est le le
le risque que le budget soit pas voté et
que donc les les fonctionnaires
américains soient plus payé plus payé et
il y avait une demande justement du
président américain de 60 milliards de
de complément pour pour l'Ukraine et il
se trouve que dans le cadre d'un d'un
arrangement il y a une suspension en
fait de ce financement pas une
annulation une suspension parce que
beaucoup de républicains pas tous mais
sont réticents à à péréniser en fait et
là on retrouve les tensions internes la
politique américaine avec effecidemment
les trumpistes alors ça on y reviendra
un peu plus tard si vous voulez bien
parce que là je voudrais rester avec
vous Patrick Martinier sur ligne de
fracture ou pas et peut-être que
d'ailleurs c'est normal après 19 mois de
de conflit au au sein du du pouvoir
ukrainien écoutez moi qui enseigne le
droit constitutionnel ça me paraît tout
à fait bizarre de voir qu'un chef de
l'armée puisse exprimer ainsi devant les
médias pour moi ça traduit une sorte de
dysfonctionnement au niveau de l'État
mais certains ukrainiens ont un avis
différent en ce sens qu'ils me disent
qu'on droit constitutionnel ukrainien le
vrai chef des armées c'est jalousen
tandis que le chef de l'État s'occupe
des affaires politiques moi je pense que
lorsque nous sommes dans un débat
démocratique il est normal que ce soit
le chef politique qui s'exprime il n'est
pas normal si vous voulez même si le
chef d'étatmajor enfin le chef des
armées pardon s'exprime pour dénoncer
une insuffisance des armement et en
disant il y a des risques que l'Ukraine
perte S cette guerre je pense qu'il y a
une responsabilité politique c'est au
chef de l'État de s'exprimer ainsi et
d'ailleurs ce dysfonctionnement est
avérri puisque de jours après les propos
du général
jalousni le chef de l'État zenaski a dit
que tout l'URE tout à fait que ce
n'était pas normal et que cela pouvait
fragiliser la défense de l'Ukraine donc
on voit bien qu'il y a un petit problème
qui à mon avis est une amorce de débat
politique qu'il y ait des débats
politiques au sein de la Rada c'est tout
à fait normal mais le parement parement
rainien voilà mais effet qu'au niveau au
plus au niveau politique et militaire
qu'il y ait ce cette sorte de petite
musique différente pour moi ça sonne
quand même comme une sorte de
dysfonctionnement au niveau de l'État
mari P votre avis c'est une tempête dans
un verre d'eau c'est un vrai signe de de
dysfonctionnement ou de
divergence plutôt une tempête dans dans
le verre d'eau mais qui enfin
euh pour revenir juste pour pour la
correction non non c'est comme en France
le c'est le président qui est le chef
enfin comment on dit
euh chef des armées et ensuite zalogen
ils ont deux titres qui sont extrêmement
similaires à à à l'oreill mais qui sont
différents euh il n'y a pas de à mon
sens mon analyse est telle qu'il n'y a
pas de
compétition réellement et il ne peut pas
y avoir parce que le rôle de militaire
euh c'est de c'est de gérer les armées
de préparer les opérations de proposer
des options ensuite c'est le le rôle des
commandant en chef quand même de prendre
la décision finale et c'est comme ça que
ça se passe ou oui mais alors je je vais
poser la question différemment je vais
poser la question différemment pardon de
vous interrompre est-ce que le
leadership de volodimir Zelenski est
remis en question alors je ne crois pas
un seul instant que le chef des forces
de le commandant en chef des forces
armées qui est Valérie zalogen et pu
s'exprimer avec un article développé
avec un article et avec un interview à
sortie présentant en plus une sorte de
de concept de nouveau concept d'aide à
l'Ukraine euh je n'ose pas penser un
instant que ça puisse euh avoir eu lieu
euh sans l'accord de la de la présidence
et de l'administration présidentielle je
pense seulement que probablement cela
n'a pas été interprété euh de de de la
manière voulue par ailleurs curieusement
plus en Ukraine qu' qu'à l'étranger
parce qu'à l'étranger le message a passé
plus ou moins bien c'est en Ukraine où
en effet on a vu comme une sorte de de
de fétisme ou le début de défétisme et
ça ça a provoqué un questionnement et ce
qui fait que maintenant le président qui
dans son rôle est laessé de rectifier le
tir et de parler à sa nation et
d'expliquer que non on voulait pas dire
ça c'est qu'on cherche tout simplement à
ajuster notre stratégie pour mieux
gagner oui et puis c'était pas n'importe
quel média David c'était économiste
grand magazine hebdomadeur américain
grand article donc est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ça est-ce que il a pu y
aller en cavalier seul le le chef
d'état-major ou ou pas parce que vu
d'ici on se dit bah non puisque 2 jours
après il est contredit par en thorie en
théorie c'est c'est difficilement
envisageable ou mais peut-être que la
teneur de certains propos euh on on ont
peut-être dépassé ce qui avait été
paramétré initialement c'est possible
donc c'est nuance et ce qui me fait dire
ça c'est la réaction de Zelenski après
qui a était quand même c'est pas un
recadrage mais enfin en partie quand
même parce qu'il s'est rendu compte il
s'est rendu compte que ça pouvait nuir
juste à la légitimité DEES demandes
vis-àvis des alliés tout discours
excusez-moi mais tout discours d'un chef
de d'étatmajor de l'armée ou même d'un
membre du gouvernement doit être
préalablement soumis à la présidence de
la République ou au Premier ministre et
on a vu que dans des temps passés ces
discours qui n'avaient pas été soumis au
Premier ministre comme en Angleterre
récemment ça crée des difficultés
politiques allez je vous redonne la
parole tout de suite allez-y si vousouêt
ça vaut la peine de préciser au
téléspectateurs de quel article il
s'agit en fait c'est c'est une sorte
d'article program de program si vous
voulez avec un petit constat que la
manière dont nous menons la guerre dont
nous nous défendons cela ne donne pas
les résultats escomptés nous devons nous
remettre en question et nous devons
faire une sorte de saut en augmentant
l'aide d'un côté mais aussi en en misant
sur l'innovation technologique donc en
fait c'était c'était plutôt un côté
programmateur si vous voulez mais tout
le monde a retenu constat que ça ne
marche pas aussi bien que nous voulions
on a
retenu
par on pourrait dire mais pouro passeant
de temps dans ce débat sur ce qui
apparaî comme une interne mais non parce
que derrière ça effectivement la
capacité de l'Ukraine à continuer
d'entraîner derrière elle une coalition
internationale à continuer d'obtenir des
armes je vous propose d'entendre un
autre commandant de l'armée ukrainienne
il s'appelle pardon pour la
prononciation ser NAF il détaille un peu
les armes dont ces soldats ont
besoin nous avons besoin d'armes à l
rayon de destruction comme le patriote
un accord a été conclu pour que de tels
systèmes nous parviennent bientôt nous
avons également besoin des célèbres
nazam iris et bien sûr des missiles qui
leur sont destinés et on va parler
justement de l'aide internationale avec
vous Jonathan duprz re bonsoir le
Royaume-Uni qui vient d'assurer Kiev de
son soutien c'était plus que bienvenu
oui c'était bienvenu l'Ukraine avait
bien besoin qu'un haut responsable
Occident
si fraîchement nommé soit-il se se
rendre à Kief et c'est quand même pas
n'importe qui c'est David Cameron on l'a
dit l'ancien Premier ministre
britannique qui est venu dire à Kief
qu'il continuera je le cite à apporter
le soutien moral diplomatique économique
mais surtout militaire le temps qu'il
faudra à l'Ukraine ouvere de soulagement
côté ukrainien parce que le Royaume-Uni
c'est derrière les États-Unis le
deuxième pourvoyeur d'aide militaire à
l'Ukraine c'est environ 5,3 milliards
d'euros symboliquement aussi cette
visite elle avait du
sens avec cette conjoncture
internationale dont vous parliez
l'Ukraine on a l'impression voilà que le
conflit a été un petit peu relégué au
second au second plan derrière le
conflit entre Israël et le Hamas donc
volodimir
Zelenski c'était plutôt inquiété de ça
il y a quelques semaines et là on voit
que ça répond à ses inquiétudes on
l'écoute la guerre au Moyen-Orient
détourne
l'attention je pense que c'est l'un des
objectifs de la Fédération de Russie
elle a compris que l'attention se porte
MOS sur
l'raine alors on a commencé à l'évoquer
avec David rigoleros tout à l'heure et
les États-Unis le principal pourvoyeur
d'aide bah oui ça c'est la grande
question le président Biden il Martelle
depuis toujours que les États-Unis
n'abandonneront pas l'Ukraine leur
soutien est primordial 43 milliards de
dollars jusqu'à présent et Joe Biden
tablait même sur une une rallonge de 61
milliards dont vous dont vous parliez
tout à l'heure mais à ce stade cette
enveloppe et ben elle est assez elle est
en suspens si on peut dire avec cet
accord budgétaire qui a été obtenu hier
au Congrès les démocrates ils voulaient
une sorte d'énorme enveloppe de
plusieurs centaines de de millions de
dollars pour l'Ukraine Israël Taïwan
mais finalement chaque aide militaire
elle sera traité séparément au prix de
négociation et ça c'est les républicains
qui exigent cela euh et l'aide
américaine en tout cas elle va se
poursuivre mais sa réduction en tout cas
ne semble plus vraiment tabou
outreAtlantique évidemment c'est en
milliards de dollars côté européen côté
européen et côté européen bah l'Union
européenne elle fait plutôt bloc en tout
cas en tant qu'entité elle a apporté 25
milliards d'euros à l'Ukraine depuis le
début de la guerre mais dans le détail
hein si on regarde les États-membres
l'indéfectible soutien semble par moment
se fissurer et de plus en plus se
fissurer après bientôt 2 ans de guerre
une contreoffensive qui patine et ben un
certain soutien de de l'Ukraine il se
désengage peu à peu c'est le cas de la
Slovaquie hein dont vous voyez le le
nouveau Premier ministre le populiste
robert Fico qui est un proorusse arrivé
au pouvoir et lui il Martelle ce message
plus une munition à l'Ukraine il résume
d'ailleurs ce qu'il pense he dans un
propos lapidaire que je vous propose
d'écouter la Slovaquie et ses habitants
ont des problèmes plus importants à
régler que l'Ukraine c'est tout ce que
j'ai à dire pour l'instant voilà un vite
expédié un message de désengagement qui
va dans le sens de Victor Orban aussi et
son front anti-armes le dirigeant
hongrois lui aussi se refuse toujours à
envoyer des armes létales euh à
l'Ukraine et il parasite aussi
méticuleusement toutes les les ambitions
de l'Union européenne pour accroître ses
financements à l'Ukraine on le voit donc
bien Thomas il y a commandême une sorte
de grande fatigue he qui s'installe du
côté des Occidentaux et évidemment avec
cette concurrence avec le conflit entre
Israël et le Hamas donc on a
l'impression quand même que cette aide
militaire à l'Ukraine elle existe
toujours mais elle se craquelle chaque
jour davantage merci beaucoup Jonathan
alors beaucoup de thématiques ça va nous
servir à lancer beaucoup de thématiques
dans dans les prochaines minutes
évidemment l'aide américaine l'aide
européenne les dissensions internes au
niveau européen mais peut-être je
voudrais commencer sur les armes Mariana
P j'ai cru comprendre je suis pas un
spécialiste mais que c'était la question
du contrôle du ciel qui qui était
vraiment problématique pour que la
contreoffensive ukrainienne puisse
progresser quelles armes manquent-t-il
au à l'armée ukrainienne pour pouvoir
reprendre le contrôle alors moi je pense
que le militaire ukrainien il a il a
déjà très bien dit ça alors premièrement
les patriotes et les et les systèmes
Allemands y restai parce que bah il se
trouve que ce sont des tout nouveaux
systèmes et qui ont prouvé leur
efficacité
h pouro parce que il faut comprendre que
quand il y a une offensive quand il y a
même des concentration des troupes avec
toutes ces toutes ces armes occidentales
qui qui est très cher qui ont été donné
il est souhaitable quand même qu'elle ne
soit pas détruite ces armes tout de
suite ave avec les Soldatens qui vont
a il faut protéger ses soldats d'accord
dans le cadre d'une offensive et de
toute opération militaire mais surtout
offensive parce que les offensif
comprennent des de de de de sortes de
concentration des armes et des hommes
vous voyez donc d'un côté mais de
l'autre côté la Russie justement elle
sait que l'Ukraine elle elle a un manque
de protection aérienne donc elle elle
continue de frapper et de terroriser les
populations civiles elle continue à
frapper les villes en obligeant les
autorités à couvrir bien surtout les
grandes villes pour protéger les civils
ce qui n donne pas assez pour le Fonton
ce qui n donne pas assez pour protéger
les les fameuses armes et les soldats
qu'il faut protéger
ce qui fait que bah oui voilà il faut il
faut il faut renforcer la protection
aérienne il faut je rajoute quand même
que la protection aérienne c'est aussi
l'aviation c'est même pour cela que
l'Ukraine dès le début de la guerre
demandait comme la première chose la
chose la principale c'est la protection
aérienne c'est le la la clé la clé de
voûte de tout si vous voulez de c'est
c'est une composante extrêmement
importante pour protéger les civils pour
que la vie civile puisse continuer dans
les territoires libres mais c'est aussi
un élément extrêmement important pour
toute opération militaire avec notamment
ce dôme de fer qu'Israël a jamais voulu
livrer au aux Ukrainiens David
rigolerose c'est c'est la démonstration
de l'impasse dont on parlait tout à
l'heure elle est pas nouvelle dire sans
ces moyens supplémentaires pour
reprendre le contrôle du ciel c'est un
peu où cette offensive peut-elle aller
sinon que c'est un peu Valérie zalouni a
souligné hein ouais notamment il y a la
question des avions des F16
effectivement euh en dehors la
sécurisation c'est aussi l'appuiefeu qui
a manqué au moment de
l'offensive c'est c'est assez inédit que
il y ait une offensive de cette ampleur
sans appui aérien et et du coup c'est
hypothéquer pour parti c'est vrai et
comme il y avait le différé de la
formation des pilotes et la livraison
c'est ça explique le le
griief poli qui formule sur le délai
trop long de livraison de certains types
d'armement ouais qui effectivement ont
hypothéqué la réussite de l'offensive
lancée ouis alors l'autre élément
important de la chronique de de
jonathanpr c'était la question de l'aide
internationale est-ce qu'elle est
atteint en quelque sorte son maximum ça
pourrait être une façon de formuler le
le le ce chapitre Patrick Martin jeunier
est-ce que l'aide internationale comment
je peux tourner ça est-ce qu'elle est
corrélée à l'avancée des troupes
ukrainiennes vous voyez ce que je veux
dire c'estàdire que est-ce que les la
coalition veut des preuves efficacité
pour continuer de de de donner autant
d'argent et autant d'Ares écoutez non je
ne pense pas après avoir écouté les
différents dirigeants occidentaux de
l'OTAN je pense que tout le monde a le
dit et vous avez cité la visite de David
Cameron sur place aujourd'hui que cette
aide allait continuer sans condition euh
en tout cas oui c'est la la volonté
affichée par l'Occident par l'OT temp
nous parlions des F16 tout à l'heure les
premers F16 donné par les Pays-Bas sont
arrivés en Roumanie devraient arriver
rapidement en Ukraine il manque
également euh les missiles de longue
portée cela a été dit toutefois on voit
bien que du congrès du côté du Congrès
américain cela a déjà été évoqué on ne
parle plus d'une aide inconditionnelle
et c'est vrai que du côté américain vous
savez les Américains c'est aussi du
business euh et bien c'est oui on va
commencer à regarder on fera un
diagnostic un état des forces et il
faudrait par exemple lorsqu'on nous dit
au Congrès américain que 96 % des
ressources ont été épuisées quelque part
sous-entendu ça veut dire oui mais ça
n'avance toujours pas comme on pouvait
l'espérer euh ce qu'avait reconnu
d'ailleurs également général jalousenie
mais je ne pense pas effectivement que
cette aide soit conditionnée à des
résultats non parce que l'Europe est
parfaitement conscience qu'il s'agit
d'un débat pour la démocratie pour les
valeurs donc on va continuer et on parle
d'ors et déjà d'un 12e train de sanction
de l'Union européenne contre la Russie
votre avis même question est-ce que
c'est corrélé ou pas ça allit pas
explicitement mais implicitement oui il
y a une ça rentre en ligne de compte
certainement euh parce que vous évoquz
la lassitude tout à l'heure à la fois
des opinions publiques et il y a un
scénario cauchemar pour pour Kief c'est
une reprise d'une forme d'offensive
d'une dynamique offensive pour les
forces russes ce qui est pas le cas
encore mais enfin il y a des poussées
dans l'est et puis l'élection de Trump
et là c'est un enjeu considérable parce
que on sait très bien que Trump n'a pas
et c'est les élus qui sont autour de lui
républicains ne veulent pas péréniser
effectivement cette aide financière et
donc c'est un enjeu considérable et il
est d'autant plus aujourd'hui qu'il y a
le théâtre pr oriental pour le coup les
élun trumpist sont pas regard sur l'aide
pour Israël mais il le sont
potentiellement sur l'aide à l'Ukraine
donc c'est c'est c'est effectivement
problématique on a titré ce débat la
guerre oubliée Mariana pu comment c'est
vécu en Ukraine le fait que depuis 40
jours 41 jours finalement les
projecteurs de médiatique mais aussi
politique ce soit détourné de votre pays
mais puisque les Ukrainiens vivent cette
guerre ils n'ont pas l'impression que
c'est une guerre oublié ne vérifie pas
la réue de presse pour savoir si si on
parle aussi on n parle pas euh après je
pense que c'est un tout petit peu
exagéré de dire qu'elle est oubliée elle
est c'est vrai elle n'est elle elle
n'est pas depuis un mois et demi elle
n'est
pas systématiquement mise en avant comme
ce fut le cas en France en tous les cas
pendant un très très très long moment
mais enfin entre nous nous com enfin
nous sommes sur un plateau télé nous
comprenons très bien comment
fonctionnent les les médias ça c'est pas
nouveau mais au-delà des médias parce
que effectivement la responsabilité
médiatique on peut on peut la mais même
dans dans l'action des diplomatiques
vous voyez ce que je veux dire dans
l'intérêt que les chefs d'État ou les
ministres des Affaires étrangère porte
au conflit ukrainien depuis depuis et
bien le meilleur exemple c'est celui
qu'on qu'onon a cité début réserve qui
réserve sa première visite de
ministreaires
étrangères il est déjà parti en Ukraine
non l'Ukraine reste quand même le sujet
géopolitique numéro 1 et et le restera
enfin pendant très très longemps jusqu'à
ce que ce on n'arrive pas à une forme
d'about d'ailleurs le secrétaire général
de l'OTAN vient de faire une déclaration
en disant que il fallait absolument
péréniser le soutien à l'Ukraine sinon
c'était potentiellement accentué la
menace russe voilà il faut il faut juste
comprendre de plusieurs chose la
première chose c'est que la guerre
elle-même elle dure alors les Ukrainiens
pour les Ukrainiens la
Guer ils nont pas remarqué que qu'elle
est qu'elle est qu'elle est partie sauf
peut-être quelques conseillers de la
présidence ukrainien ukrainienne qui ont
écrit quelques discours à zelensk qui a
cru bon de dire plusieurs fois dans des
entretiens bon ben maintenant on parle
plus de nous c'est me paraît étrange
très honnêtement C para étrange mais
parle d'emmanu Macon dans
la quand même c'est aussi une guerre de
la communication et donc les médias sont
présents et donc il y a quand même le
sentiment sur le plan international
qu'on voit moins l'Ukraine sur les
écrans veut pas
direul les discours repris en ouverture
des journaux du du monde entier
évidemment ça a eu un impact dans la
mobilisation interur il faut il faut il
faut tout just il faut quand même
rappeler que depuis le début de la
guerre il y a eu 12000 journalistes qui
ont été accrédités pour couvrir la
guerre c'est ce sont des chiffres sans
précédent en fait c'est une couverture
exceptionnelle il n'y a pas eu de de
retours massif des journalistes de
l'Ukraine il y a toujours des milliers
de journalistes Ukrainiens mais surtout
des journalistes internationaux qui
continuent à travailler en Ukraine qui
continuent à produire de la formation du
reporting et on voit toujours ces
reportages euh soit dans les médias
audiovisuels soit dans la presse écrite
c'est juste qu'on peut-être on on on on
s'adapte à le faire de manière à ce que
ça ne soit pas systématiquement
actualité brûlante mais peut-être sous
d'autres angle mais je pense que c'est
c'est exagéré de dire que c'est une
guerre
oubliée qu'on a choisi on l'assume en
tout cas c'est peut-être vu d'ici par
notre prisme français et et ce qui
apporte de l'eau à à ce choix de titre
on je me tourne vers vous mathde Siro
c'est aussi l'agenda diplomatique et
notamment l'agenda diplomatique du
président français effectivement on
entend évidemment moins le président
français sur s'exprimer sur le front
ukrainien alors la dernière entrevue
entre Emmanuel Macron et volodimir
Zelenski elle remonte au 5 octobre donc
avant effectivement ce qui le
déclenchement de la guerre au Proche
Orient c'était lors d'un sommet européen
à Grenade et le dernier échange entre
les deux présidents remonte au 18
octobre donc il y
a presque un mois et le chef de l'État
français avait alors réitéré justement
son soutien à à son homologue et on peut
également citer que la semaine dernière
c'est l'épouse du président ukrainien
qui a été reçu par Brigit Macron à
l'Élysée on dit quoi à l'Élysée
là-dessus à l'élsée justement on dit que
l'Ukraine est une attention en continu
donc c'est pour rassurer aussi Kief à ce
propos et la présidence fait savoir que
Paris compte bien nourrir et entretenir
la relation
pour ne pas donner l'impression
effectivement de baisser la garde et
sans établir de hiérarchie entre ces
différentes crises internationales c'est
un parlementaire de la majorité très
impliqué sur ces questions ukrainiennes
qui soulligne que le conflit
russo-ukrainien emporte beaucoup plus de
conséquences directes pour l'avenir de
la France et de l'Europe d'autant qu'il
y a un certain nombre d'échéances dont
il faut parler effectivement on en a
parlé hein la question d'un nouveau
train de sanction qui se pose la
question aussi de l'élarg avec le
Conseil européen du 15 décembre sur
l'ouverture des négociations d'adhésion
avec l'Ukraine et aussi la Moldavie il y
a aussi les 2 ans de la guerre à venir
le 24 février avec cette menace qui
plane d'une nouvelle offensive russe cet
hiver les ministres français les
parlementaires français se rendent
régulièrement en Ukraine Emmanuel Macron
sa dernière visite remonte à juin 2022
il y était allé à l'époque avec
l'allemand Olaf Scholz et l'Italien
Mario dragi on s'en souvient de de cette
image très marquante dans le train et
c'est pourquoi Thomas selon nos
informations une visite est à l'étude du
président Emmanuel Macron en Ukraine
peut-être au mois de décembre en janvier
c'est pas tout à fait calé pour
l'instant et comme à chaque fois le
président se déplacera à une condition
celle de pouvoir être utile comme il le
dit c'est-à-dire à la condition de ne
pas venir les mains vides et donc de
pouvoir annoncer quelque chose de
nouveau sur cette question Patrick
Martin jeunier la France mais aussi les
les merci beaucoup ma les autres pays de
de de cette coalition qui soutient
l'Ukraine depuis depuis plus de 19 mois
est-ce qu'il prépare la suite là est-ce
qu'il se projette déjà dans
d'éventuelles négociations de paix et
bien écoutez ça c'est la grande
difficulté c'est un peu tabou hein bien
évidemment que tout le monde se projette
après cette guerre notamment pour la
reconstruction les États-Unis l'Europe
seront là l'Union européenne sera là
pour aider la reconstruction c'est quand
même le chantier principal mais bien
évidemment se pose la question vous
l'avez cité des négociations d'adhésion
la Commission européenne vient de me
rendre un avis favorable et certains
estiment et le président zéinsk en
premier que ça devrait prendre 2 ans il
a évoqué le délai de 2 ans qui me semble
tout à fait irréaliste mais il est en
train de nous dire oui il faut accélérer
et on veut le début des négociations ce
qui ve dire sur l'entrée de l'ukraineée
dans l'Union européne il y a même
l'ancien secrétaire général de l'oton
sans attendre la fin de la guerre euh
oui sans attendre la fin de la guerre le
déébut des négociation à tel point que
certains disent mais je sais que c'est
un peu t euh mais les opinions divergent
un peu même en Ukraine que l'Ukraine
pourrait rentrer dans l'Union européenne
même même amputée d'une certaine partie
de son territoire tout le monde n'est
pas d'accord ce qui veut dire que faire
rentrer l'Ukraine après tout il y a un
précédent c'est Chypre non mais il y a
un précédent c'est Chypre même si ce
n'est pas exactement la même situation
certains estiment que on pourra rentrer
dans l'Union européenne même si
effectivement l'intégrité territoriale
n'est pas complètement reprise recouv
c'est ça aujourdhui le grand débat et
même l'ancien secrétaire général de l'an
monsieur rasmen a ditah finalement si on
fait ça pour l'Union européne on
pourrait peut-être effectivement
accélérer aussi l'entrée dans l' temp
voilà où on en est aujourd'hui ce sont
différentes hypothèses que j'évoque dans
un article de la revue parlementaire du
début de semaine excusez-moi de faire de
la publicité mais ENF je analys tout
jeai je l'ai lu pour préparer cette
émission voilà donc c'est effectivement
une hypothèse qui était mise même si il
y a des débats en Ukraine sur ce point
j'ai entendu des Ukrainiens me dire mais
oui après tout il faut accélérer et donc
même rentrer dans cette hypothèse
regarder Chypre ça fait 40 ans que ça
dure la partie amputée de Chipre et bien
finalement sur le plan juridique on
considère dans l'Union européne que
c'est tout ché pour qui est ce qui veut
dire que si l'Ukraine rentrait de cette
façon dans l'Union européenne ce serait
une sorte de fiction politique toute
l'Ukraine y serait sauf dans les fêes
les territoires occupés David rigolose
votre avis là-dessus est-ce que c'est
une fiction aujourd'hui d'imaginer des
des discussions de de de paix
effectivement avec une Ukraine qui
aurait pas récupéré la totalité de son
terrire en même des débats internes à
l'Ukraine il y a des oppositions en
Europe Victor Orban est est contre
l'adhésion ou donc il peut mettre s là
je parle de la de je parle au-delà de
l'adhésion je parle de la la fin du
conflit quoi vous voyez ce que veux dire
bah pour l'instant il y a un grand point
d'interrogation parce que au début on
pensait que ce serait un
conflit relativement rapide et puis on
s'est inscrit dans la durée c'était le
calcul de Vladimir Poutine d'ailleurs il
s'inscrivaent dans le tlon et le tlon
l'horloge profite à la Russie plus qu'à
l'Ukraine c'est problème c'était pour ça
que l'enjeu était considérable sur la
côreofensive justement ukrainienne et ça
rejoint la question de l'aide
internationale voilà pendant combien de
temps peut-elle rester à un tel niveau
s'il y a pas de grandes avancées
militaires on je renvoie au scénario
cauchemar pour Zelenski et Kief d'une
élection éventuelle de Donald Trump qui
remettrait en cause systématiquement le
qui avait dit d'ailleurs qu'il réglerait
en 48 he la question de manière un peu
un peuière oui c'est ça et et et puis il
y a quand même une érosion partielle des
opinions publiques on le sent alors même
si le soutien est maintenu mais il y a
quand même ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure une forme de fatigue de
lassitude justement parce que on ne voit
pas de
perspective solide ouais Mariana P
l'objectif évidemment c'est c'est c'est
c'est toujours comme ça en cas de
conflit c'est de gagner le plus de
terrain possible pour pouvoir négocier
en position de force je parle pas de
l'entrée dans l'Union là je parle
vraiment d'une sortie du du confit alors
je pense je pense que ça a été
effectivement une stratégie inavouée
parfois inavouée à à des mimots euh de
des alliés de l'Ukraine en qui ont tablé
sur le fait que en infligeant de perte
de de telles pertes à la Russie la
Russie sera obligée de de négocier et
donc en fait que l'idée de tout cela
c'était d'enfliger de de de perte à la
Russie mais c'est même pour ça que je
j'ai envie de poser la question mais
vraiment à tout le monde à ce qu'on à ce
qu'on fasse une sorte de reality check
quel sont des des des des signes est-ce
qu'on a vu au moins un seul signe depuis
un an et demi que la Russie veuille
négocier quoi que ce soit en fait et sur
quoi se basait-on en se
disant sur quoi se basiton en disant que
si on enlige assez de pertes à la Russie
la Russie sera obligée de de reculer et
bien non on s'est basé peut-être sur le
bon sens parce que quand on quand on a
trop de pertes quand on a trop de pertes
peut-être que ça coûte trop cher et bien
le bon sens voudrait qu'on qu' qu'on
qu'on renonce et bien non Vladimir
Poutine la Russie de Vladimir Poutine
tout tout comme les r de Ch c'éit pas
c'était pas queul le calcul éventuel des
alliés puisque c'est ce que reconnaît
zalouni lui-même donc le chef
d'étatmajor des armées dont on parla
tout
à il il le reconnaî il est très je pense
que pour les Ukrainiens c'était plutôt
l'espoir al j'ai fait une erreur j'ai
cru que les 150000 pertes
russes effectivement euh F serait un
Game changer et il reconnaît que ça n'a
pas été le cas donc et donc il faut
quand même revenir à la réalité et
vraiment il faut comprendre que la
Russie de Vladimir Poutine tout comme
tout comme les rang de de Mola c'est
c'est un autre régime il vivent dans un
autre système ils ont d'autres
motivations en fait qui qui qui sont
autres que le bon sens je suis d'accord
avec vous
mais pour l'Ukraine mais l'Ukraine peut
pardon de vous interrompre l'raine ne
peut continuer cette guerre que si
l'aide internationale se maintient au
niveau actuel et on vient d'évoquer
l'hypothèse que que ce ce que c'est
qu'elle se tarisse en tout tout parti
cette aide internationale donc la
question de la sortie du conflit elle va
bien se poser à un moment ou un autre
non mais un jour elle va se poser c'est
pour ça que j'ai rien ne rien n'endque
par ailleurs que la Russie voudra
négocier même le jour si admettons
l'Ukraine regagne son intégrité
territoriale et ça il faut aussi tenir
en compte il y a des pays comme ça qui
sont dans une une sorte de guerre il y a
même pas d'armistice même s'il y a pas
de guerre intense c'est même pour cela
que il est temps de regarder dans la
venir il me semble c'est même pour cela
que c'est quand même bienvenu qu'on
qu'on commence à sérieusement envisager
l'adhésion dans l'Union européenne et
l'adhésion dans le temp parce que
justement ça ça peut être des
instruments qui peuvent garantir la
sécurité à l'Ukraine en absence de
victoire militaire ou cela c'est cela
qui peut garantir à l'Ukraine ou ne
serait-ce qu'au civil ukrainien euh
la sécurité dans les villes libres cela
peut garantir le retour de réfugiés
parce qu'il faut dire quand même qu'il y
a encore beaucoup de réfugiés qui
restent en Europe qui ne reviennent pas
parce qu'ils ont peur parce que ce sont
souvent des femmes avec les enfants et
parce qu'il y a des frappes encore il y
a des alertes tous les tous les jours
donc c'est normal que que les on a peur
de cela quand on a des enfants en basage
par exemple donc il est temps de
réfléchir quand même à à l'avenir mais
sur les bases réalistes ouais il nous
reste un peu moins de 5 minutes dans ce
débat je voudrais aborder un dernier
thème sur la la la situation économique
en Ukraine l'économie de de guerre je
propose d'écouter la pray de la
Commission européenne Ursula van derlen
elle était en visite à Kiev le 4
novembre dernier elle dit il faut qu'on
trouve le moyen de faire payer la
Russie globalement la Russie doit payer
le prix de la dévastation et de la
destruction qu'à la cause et dans ce
contexte il y a un exemple il s'agit du
produit des 200 milliards d'euros
d'actifs sou russe immobilisé en Europe
ces bénéfices s'accumulent chaque
jour et nous pensons qu'il devrait être
consacré à la reconstruction de
l'Ukraine Patrick Martin quand on parle
d'économie de guerre ça veut dire quoi
que l'argent de l'aide internationale il
sert à quoi audelà des armes par exemple
au-delà des armes donc d'abord
effectivement bon c'est quand même
important nous n'avons nous sommes pas
nous en économie de guerre hier donc on
peut pas produire plus que ce qu'on a
mais très clairement ce que veut faire
la Commission européenne c'est de
mobiliser tout toutes les entreprises
tout le secteur privé pour la
reconstruction de l'Ukraine faut pas
oublier non plus que la Commission
européenne grâce à son budget elle
soutient à bout de bras l'économie
ukrainienne notamment pour payer les
fonctionnaires payer les instituteurs
payer les infirmiers infirmières qui
font un travail remarquable et donc
aujourd'hui la difficulté c'est ce dire
jusqu'à quand devrons-nous effectivement
soutenir de cette façon l'économie et
euh effectivement ce qu'à dire la
falaran c'est qu'elle va continuer à
soutenir financièrement mais on voit
bien aujourd'hui que il y aura un moment
donné on est en train de négocier le
cadre financier pluri-annuel pour les 7
8 années années qui viennent pour
l'Union européenne et bien ça va être
extrêmement difficile parce que à
supposer en espérant que l'Ukraine
rentre dans l'Union européenne cela va
entraîner une une révision totale de la
politique agricole commune des fonds
structurels et tout cela nous n nous
n'avons pas les moyens aujourd'hui très
clairement et donc c'est ça aujourd'hui
qui risque de poser des difficultés au
Conseil européen de la semaine prochaine
mais il faut essayer en tout cas de
continuer à avancer et je crois que la
Commission européenne et sur une ligne
de continuer à aider financièrement
l'Ukraine David R je reprends l'idée de
de la préent de la Commission européenne
les 200 milliards d'euros d'actif
souverain russes immobilisés en Europe
qui qui font des petits là qui font des
bénéfices c'est si facile de les de les
capter pour les redonner à l'raine c'est
pas du tout facile c'est le problème
parce que ça remet en cause
effectivement des normes internationales
par rapport à des
à des fonds publics liés à des banques
et cetera et c'est évidemment c'est
c'est Tanton mais c'est dit c'est du bon
sens presque oui mais c'est très
compliqué à mettre en œuvre parce que ce
serait remettre en cause un certain
nombre de principes qui qui sont des
normes internationales et et c'est là où
ça devient compliqué parce qu'évidemment
en terme d'équité on pourrait trouver ça
logique mais en terme de normatif c'est
beaucoup plus problématique et ça
pourrait induire en cascade des effets à
long terme négatifs par rapport aux
effets supposés positifs initiaux donc
c'est c'est compliqué en revanche pour
le pour l'aide effectivement il y a il y
a un aspect qui est important on
l'oublie souvent autant l'aide militaire
et massivement américaine autant l'aide
effectivement civile notamment à
l'économie pour pour laisser le pour
permettre au pays de surnager elle est
essentiellement européenne c'est vrai
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat je vais rappeler
oublier la guerre merci à vous pour ne
pas oublier la guerre B on essae on
essae mais on a mis du temps quand même
certaine façon ça fait 40 jours bref je
vais citer le titre de votre livre
Patrick Martin jeunier l'Europe a-t-elle
un avenir livre publié aux éditionssh
studirama notez votre prochain
rendez-vous sur notre antenne la
matinale évidemment avec Oriane monsini
Orian qui reçoit les cistes et
conseillers politiqu à la main que ce
sera à 8h du matin sur notre antenne
belle soirée sur public sénna et je vous
dis à
lundi
[Musique]